فقاعه لم تكن عابره فبالون التجسس الصيني
يشغل بال الامريكيين حتى بعد خمسه اشهر
على اسقاطه النتائج الاوليه للتحليلات
التي اجرتها واشنطن على حطام البالون كشفت
استخدام الصين لتكنولوجيا الامريكيه في
جاسوس الطائر بالون تجسس الصيني الذي طاف
فوق الولايات المتحده كان مقتضا بمعدات
امريكيه الصنع متاحه تجاريا وبعضها يباع
عبر الانترنت فحطامه اظهر اجهزه استشعار
متخصصه والواحا شمسيه للطاقه وغيرها من
المعدات لجمع الصور ومقاطع الفيديو مسؤلون
امريكيون اكدوا دعم هذه النتائج
لاستنتاجات الاوليه القائله بان المركبه
كانت مخصصه للتجسس وليس لمراقبه الطقس كما
قالت لكنهم قللوا من امكانيه ارسال تلك
المركبه للبيانات المجموعه الى الصين وفق
صحيفه
فكان اعضاء الكونجرس يضغطون على اداره
بايدن لكشف ما تعرفه عن قدرات المنطاد
وسبب سماحها للمركبه بالمرور فوق قواعده
ومنشات عسكريه حساسه كما انتقد بعضهم تاخر
الاداره باصدار تقريرها علما بان الاخيره
ترفض حتى اللحظه نشره نتائجها حول المنطاد
علنا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات